hello everybody and welcome to part 8 of
let's play from dust I just wanted to
give you a little overview of what these
stories that I've been collecting
throughout the game were um they're just
little tidbits about stuff about the
game like the shaman the village the man
good good at nothing yeah animals
different stuff like that it's
interesting stuff to read but it would
take way too long to go through each one
of these and I'm not gonna put you
through that okay where we left off we
had just finished populating this totem
and we found out that the other totem is
over here and I got to get to there so
it seems to be a bit of water around so
kind of clean it up a bit so that my
guys can go over there cuz I'm pretty
sure they're gonna go over the mountain
there and I'm not I'll get out of your
water
Oh Oh Oh got you got your fire oh no no
no don't even try it
alright let's send them to go over here
JC JC get rid of the sand and my jellify
the water or evaporate it if I evaporate
would it evaporate the entire ocean
worth the try to me ah Oh what what's
happening what's happened oh not again
oh not again not again oh not again I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry ah what have I
done
oh the humanity oh no oh no oh no either
so useless
oh no I'm oh I feel bad oh oh goodness
gracious
oh goodness gravy oh goodness gravy oh
goodness
like golly gosh that fire isn't does not
want to stop okay evaporate oh no I just
evaporated off the water
Oh probably bad thing considering
water is necessary okay doesn't seem to
be evaporating the ocean so jellify the
water real quick all right hang on hang
on oh my god everyone's dying everyone
is dying man it's some deep water Oh get
out of here sand oh I do not want to
mess with you right now
I've got damn there's way too much water
maybe this was a mistake maybe I should
have built the bridge because this looks
like it's getting pretty damn deep yeah
this this is a problem okay man
maybe it's like cuz it's separate from
the rest of them if it could just pulled
all the water out anyway oh look at that
oops that's not good okay oh boy that's
like oh no oh no oh they died Oh
everyone's dead oh no everyone's dead oh
no oh no no oh boy wowie wowie wow wow
well Ivan I'm not doing a good job at
protecting these people oh I'm not oh
get away fire aah
Oh Sam water aah it's everywhere oh no
all that I know that I know that I knows
oh no I hate this fire I hate it what's
the worst oh man oh I don't even know
where to start I can't look at one thing
without completely missing out on
another all right I'm gonna put these
these do no good Oh No oh man
oh this this is horrible horrifying oh
oh no oh no oh no
Oh No I'll see you did nothing guy oh
you are useless even that even that did
nothing to stop that oh man that's the
worst alright let me try to put better
defenses here I put this right at the
apex should lock it or maybe I should
put two inside oh I don't want Sam I do
not want Sam give me that give me that
put that there then put this one on the
other side and maybe my people will live
long enough to see another day I don't
know maybe you think this whole thing
being flooded with water might help but
apparently it does not Oh No it screw it
I'm just gonna flood it all alright fine
oh not a building best bridge I can I
don't even know if this is the right way
I don't think there's enough cuz there
aren't really many sandy places
okay oh boy I'm going about this the
wrong way aren't I I'm doing something
wrong
okay maybe I sure can't tell ah
all right oh here's some Sam okay plenty
is cool all right
ah oh no I'm sorry I'm sorry what's
going on what's happening what's
happening what's happening what's
happening oh boy oh boy okay you're okay
you're okay you're okay everything's
cool
oh that's not good nope that wasn't
enough oh man I can I can't keep up
it's like juggling ten million balls at
once I can't do it I'm not a good ball
juggler
all right still trying to I mean this
has got to work eventually it's just
it's bland there's a bottom I imagine
so I'm just make a fool out of myself
really grab water there's all that sand
and you grab the water ah oh oh cool
they're gonna die but now that's cool
anything that comes to this Islands
gonna die I feel so bad for these people
ah what what oh stop panicking you're
fine stop being such babies goodness oh
that's a new one
look at that oh you remember that fear I
mentioned about things with a lot of
holes in it I think I looked it up I
think it's Tripta phobia triple-triple
phobia yeah it's a real thing
like the backs of those frogs that like
they lay their eggs on their back and
then oh man and then the baby frogs
punch out of the holes and swim towards
the surface it's really disgusting so go
look it up yeah go look it up on YouTube
it's phenomenal I think I'm finally
getting there almost battle Marv Elmo
sir
oh come on God I'm gonna move the whole
island just to fill this one guy I'm
ignoring you I'm sure you're fine oh man
there are people that were really dying
crying for help and I tried to help him
and I didn't because I couldn't or uh um
I'm too bad at this game
be able to but you know cry for help for
a real thing all right there we go all
right here we go okay
almost there can you cross that now this
is the one that can move fire trees
which I'm really gonna need I'm gonna
need to move these quick because I know
vegetation is gonna sprout up here and
then they're gonna be like dying
instantly cuz there's like one to eight
fire trees goodness gravy alright go go
my little guys go well one of the
commoners mentioned to us that I sounded
like Brian Regan joke and yes yes a
million times yes I love Brian Regan if
you don't know who he is don't look him
up he's one of the funniest comedians in
the world in the world oh man he's
hilarious he's got a lot of uh that well
he doesn't but people have a lot of his
videos on YouTube it's he's phenomenal I
cannot recommend him enough he's
hilarious you will thank me go look I'm
Brian Regan BR I am re GaN Regan alright
enough of that he better give me a lot
of money for that recommendation but
anyway alright almost there almost there
come on you can do it you can do it man
go go go kiss that stone oh yeah you got
there first sorry I mispronounced at
Final Fantasy name is Mughal Mughal all
right come on come on I gotta be quick
on this all right
ready I'm ready I'm so ready I'm so
ready get that tree village going yeah
yeah Oh No fires are burning fires are
burning fires are burning fires are
burning okay okay go away son how long
has that been there okay
Oh get me out here go in the water yeah
perfect spot okay here where there's no
vegetation Oh God oh goodness look at
this ah
shup you don't even try it yeah oh yeah
finally
and these fire trees are annoying okay
you all in a bunch here right on the
mountain okay
good the vegetation hasn't quite gotten
there yet quite and gotten quite gotten
I can talk I can English speak ah
Oh get away almost there
oh don't even try it don't even try it
come here come here
there we go okay finally that Islands
good oh these are getting out of here
oh my goodness gonna be little fire
mountains Oh Oh get out of here
there we go alright that's one or that's
two what's more like eleven well oh no
oh no oh no this will bad oh the ocean
all the ocean Oh
ah I got a dam that up before that
happens oh no oh no it's shrinking oh uh
uh uh uh ah crisis Crisis crisis is a
good game
Oh get it dammed up oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh oh okay well I need to think before I
do stuff okay yeah don't let this happen
all right Dam up you damn you up up you
damn alright
alright I'll finish that later I gotta
cut it here thank you guys so much for
watching I really do appreciate every
single one of you who is subscribed to
me who's like given me all your support
I really appreciate so thank you so much
for watching and I will see you in part
9 of let's play from dust bye bye